ja das thema das uns bewegt auch meine
landsleute gerade in diesen tagen obwohl
wir natürlich vorher waren diese gefahr
und diesen
vernichtungskrieg putins haben
gleichzeitig versuchen auch die ukraine
in die zukunft zu blicken und gesten und
heute gab es diesen gipfel in paris ja
wo unter anderem auch darum ging wo
möchten die eu-staaten die ukraine sehen
nur als ein partner wie bis heute oder
doch auch als mitglied dieser familie
und dass die deutschen das haupt dass
die ampel regierung da wieder auf die
bremse getreten hat das dass man nicht
dieser historische chance die man hat
man hat man sieht dieses volkmann man
sieht wie wie die ukraine nicht nur für
heimat aber auch für diese werte für die
demokratie für die freiheit da gerade
stehen und kämpfen das was auch für die
eu aus machte und diese chance wieder zu
verpassen und nicht die führungskraft zu
zeigen nicht wieder
auch andere staaten es gibt viele
staaten die skeptischer sind ja die
haben sich da gezeigt aber deutschland
möchte diese führende kraft in europa
bleiben und
und diese chance jetzt nicht zu nutzen
sondern einfach zu sagen nein und wieder
in diesem kleinen zu verharren also das
hat viele meiner landsleute sehr
enttäuschte und es ist schade dass dass
man die fehler der vergangenheit die man
begangen hat in bezug auf
waffenlieferungen auf auf eine
annäherung seite kremation hätte man so
viel dunkeln auch russland politik die
er krachend gescheitert ist das alles
könnte man mit mit einem mit einer
mutigen entscheidung
durchkreuzen sagen liebe ukraine und
ukrainer wir bewundern ihren mut und wir
wollen sie in dieser familie sehen das
hat man leider immer noch verpasst ich
stimme ihnen vollkommen zu es geht gar
nicht darum diesen wahnsinnig
komplizierten prozess des eu beitritts
der sich über jahre hinzieht angleichung
von gesetzen und so weiter in gang zu
setzen das geht jetzt nicht da hat auch
in kiew keiner ein nerv für darum geht
es überhaupt nicht sondern man hätte als
politisches signal sage ich mal einen
sonderstatus für die ukraine prägen
müssen müssen auf diesem gipfel der
feigheit das wäre eine eine ein riesen
rückhalt für die ukrainischen kämpfer
gewesen wenn die neben der eigenen
flagge auch die europäische flagge
hätten zeigen können in dem was ich
jetzt ne ukraine abspielt aber welche
die puschen darauf reagiert wenn das
passiert wäre das haushalt des
symbolischen sein das wäre dann passt ja
das ist ja kein militärbündnis die eu
das
als signal der unterstützung durch durch
die europäische union da darf man sich
gar nicht von irritieren lassen dass
werden waffen geliefert das ist ja schon
ganz eindeutig aus allen möglichen eu
staaten und zu sagen dieses land wird
künftig wir können noch nicht genau
sagen wann der eu angehören das ist eine
geschichte die man wird später über die
fehler des westens reden und das gehört
ganz sicher zu den fehlern des westens
ich hoffe dass die nicht so schwer sind
dass die ukraine wirklich existenziell
drunter leitet es gibt ja auch gründe
warum menschen dagegen sind das wollen
wir nicht unseren tisch weil wir ein
grund ist zwar die korruption ja wenn
ich die frage mal umdrehen was hätte die
ukraine in den letzten jahren wo sie
heute sagen wer mir damals schneller
gewesen hätten wir das besser gemacht
das wollen wir in der zukunft tun aber
es gibt punkte in der vergangenheit die
haben wir auch nicht gut gemacht die
würden wir gerne anders mich ja so wie
wir sind bereit auch eigene fehler immer
zu anzuerkennen das ist kein thema und
beim thema korruption hat man sich
wirklich bemüht ja das ist nicht so dass
man das thema einfach ignoriert hat ganz
im gegenteil hat strukturen geschaffen
um dieses übel zu bekämpfen und das dach
und wissen auch die deutschen freunde
aber darauf jetzt heute ankommt ist
nimmt diese mutige entscheidung erstellt
sogar im koalitionspapier
der vertrag heißt ja mehr vor schritt
wagen und das was man heute tut wenn man
man zementiert den stillstand in diesem
land das ist das auch in bezug auf auf
uns denn wir sind hier auf einem
kontinent ja und dieser krieg wird
hoffentlich schneller als später zu ende
gehen und wir werden das land aufbauen
und und wir wollen die in die zukunft
blicken und das ist das was fehlt ja
dass diese weitsicht diese weitsicht
hier in der deutschen politik die
ukraine die aus diesem krieg auskunft
ist doch auf jeden fall eine ganz andere
als die die es vorher gegeben hat
genauso wie ist dass deutschland ein
ganz anderes ist dass aus diesem krieg
rauskommt und jetzt 100 milliarden in
die rüstung steckt werde dann das jemals
für möglich gehalten hätte man muss ja
also dann muss man darüber reden welche
regierung regiert in kiew welche partei
ist das was stellen sie sich vor gibt es
eine neue präsidentschaftswahlen usw da
muss man dann von brüssel aus und den
anderen hauptstädten versuchen darauf
einfluss zu nehmen aber man muss finde
ich verdammt noch mal in diesem feigen
eu europa man muss doch einen
schutzschirm über der ukraine aufspannen
und nicht nur unterm tisch waffen
liefern so weit es geht ein politischen
schutzschirm und das sind wir der
ukraine schuldig
paul-luca kann man alles kennen sich so
gut ausgesucht in dem thema ist die
ukraine fitness fragen sie auch sehr
sehr viele deutsch also ist das lang
nicht bereit für die eu-aufnahme
wenn wir das nach den maßstäben bewerten
die wir immer genommen haben dann ist
die klare antwort nein aber wir sind
eben in einer sondersituation in einer
situation wo wir die verdammte
moralische pflicht haben dieses land
besser zu unterstützen was wir bislang
nicht geschafft haben aber unabhängig
von der debatte sind für mich heute noch
zwei weitere bilder auffällig gewesen
zum einen wie dort getagt wurde dass das
ganze im schloss versailles
stattgefunden hat und die fotos die ich
dort gesehen habe wann vom presseteam
von ursula von der leyen mit
kronleuchtern alle haben gelacht und
gescherzt zumindest auf dem foto das ich
gesehen habe ich fand die symbolik
falsch in dem moment und was mir
aufgefallen ist ist die reise von
annalena baerbock nämlich zu herrn vucic
nach serbien und serbien hat man
hingegen gesagt dass das alles ganz
schnell gehen soll und wir erinnern uns
im herbst war in den vergangenen jahren
einer der größten unterstützer von
wladimir putin in vielen dingen in
serbien wurde zuletzt massiv protestiert
auch in
unterstützung von wladimir putin und
deswegen ist das ganze natürlich
auch kritisch zu sehen
ich hab dich zu ergänzen noch mal ich
habe den eindruck die ukraine ist
eigentlich viel proeuropäische als die
eu die madame proteste beispielsweise
dass das waren proteste die deshalb
entstanden sind weil die ukraine
unbedingt ein assoziierungsabkommen mit
der eu haben wollten gegen den damaligen
russland treuen präsidenten janukowitsch
und dass die eu ist über all diese jahre
nicht geschafft hat auch nur irgendein
zeichen zu setzen dass die ukraine nicht
egal ist abgesehen von einigen
symbolischen handlungen finde ich sehr
schade es liegt natürlich an der
uneinigkeit innerhalb der eu durch
serbien angesprochen wir haben gesehen
bulgarien tut sich beispielsweise schwer
aber jetzt finde ich ist es eigentlich
die chance zu zeigen dass die ukraine
uns wichtig ist und besser spät als nie
ja und es wäre eine schöne geste wenn
der bundeskanzler scholz malt auch heute
massiv kommen würde und sagen würde ich
bin ein kerl mit den jetzt auf dem
majdan platz das wäre doch was schon ist
für die menschen aber auch für die
deutschen würde es gut tun das sollte
ihr wunsch eine urlaubs schwer unter
anderem ich meine das ist glaube ich
dann gesagt einfach die flagge zu zeigen
und zu sagen leute wir sind mit ihnen
also wir verstanden uns nicht hinten ja
diese fassade von den wahrheiten die wir
immer wieder für richtig gehalten haben
sondern wir sind bereit auch das was wir
noch vor was noch vor wenigen wochen als
als beide die letzte instanz kalte das
ganze zu hinterfragen und diesen ukraine
auch die hand auszustrecken das ist
gerade das was man sich wünschen würde
und wie gesagt auch gleich zeigen die
entwickeln eine kraft dass man dass man
sagt ja wir sind mit mit ihnen und nicht
immer wieder sagen ja aber das und das
müssen noch gemacht und wir wissen wir
kennen unsere hausaufgaben die werden
2014 gemacht im rahmen dieses abkommens
mit der eu das wir haben es ist nicht so
dass wir jetzt plötzlich erwachsen und
sagen wir wollen in die eu nein das
steht in der verfassung wir haben darauf
hingearbeitet seit jahren und ich weiß
dass wir wirklich wenn auf einem gutem
wege sind auch was die was die
rechtsvorschriften angeht was das
kommunizieren geht das alles wissen wir
und das wird auch unternommen aber was
fehlt ist dieses politische zeichen
ihren berlin und berlin hat hier eine
besondere rolle zu spielen und darauf
warten auch die menschen in der ukraine
paul ich hab dich bereit hinter mir du
weißt was dazu sagen ja ich wollte mein
genau ich würde ein gefühl teilen was
ich hier immer mehr bekommen nämlich
eine große enttäuschung gegenüber
deutschland ist nämlich sowohl war im
umfeld des präsidenten ich nehme es war
im umfeld auch des bürgermeisters also
bei allen politischen akteuren jetzt
keine enttäuschung mit den deutschen die
ja wahnsinnig viel spenden- und
solidarität zeigen und unterstützung
zeigen sondern mit der bundesregierung
mit olaf scholz mit der frage wie olaf
scholz bislang in dieser krise agiert
und die jörges hat schon angesprochen
öl- und gas-embargo gibt es immer noch
nicht bei eu unterstützt man nicht bei
der frage was man sozusagen in den
sanktionen schneller machen könnte ist
deutschland immer hinten und viele
fragen sich hier warum ist das so also
es gibt glaube ich auch so höre ich
zumindest durchaus probleme was die
kommunikation dort an geht mit
deutschland mit der deutschen
bundesregierung
da gibt es einen außenpolitischen
berater von olaf scholz der blöd nach
der war schon unter jens böther der war
schon unter frank walter steinmeier in
führender funktion und der natürlich
auch ein verhältnis gegenüber russland
geprägt hat dass er sozusagen um
ausgleich und dialog bemüht war und die
frage ist ob so jemand denn diese 180
grad wende wirklich vollziehen kann und
glaubwürdig dafür steht und da würde
mich die meinung von anderen wenig
interessieren
der botschafter hat ja auch darüber
gesprochen wie er olaf scholz war
nämlich wie eine wand glaube ich haben
sie gesagt
in der tat das ist leider etwas was was
man immer wieder spürt und dann meine
ich meinen präsidenten vor allem weil
wir versuchen auch diese gespräche zu
intensivieren dass man immer wieder jede
woche ein zweimal spricht auf der
höchsten ebene hier in berlin und da
stößt man immer wieder auf taube ohren
und aber jetzt erkennt man auch den
wahren grund nämlich weil diese debatte
über den importstopp hat gezeigt dass
deutschland sich quasi an groß und
angekettet hat in dieser abhängigkeit
und das heißt man kann gar nichts jetzt
sagen oder oder man kann auch keine
mutige politik gegenüber russland
vielleicht fortsetzen wenn man weiß dass
wenn putin jetzt dass du etwas was
eigentlich wir von deutschland erwarten
nämlich diesen pfad für öl und gas und
kohle dann ist vielleicht oder könnte
auch die wirtschaft hier kollabiert und
nicht nur das das die menschen frieren
würden oder ein bulli dann tragen
sollten in der wohnung sondern dass das
wird ja bedeutet auch einen herben
schlag dazu kommen die wirklich danach
zum frieren und ob das für die freiheit
jetzt sein sollte und jetzt werden aber
mich interessiert noch eine sache
das genauso ich finde das sehr
faszinierend was was andere nicht
abgeschrieben hat wie muss man sich das
vorstellen also wie würde mir so lenski
und olaf scholz miteinander telefonieren
geht das per videowand was ist ihr
gefühl wie ihr präsident momentan auf
olaf scholz schaut und was fragt olaf
scholz dann sagt er dann zum lycee
lenski im verdunkelten präsidentenpaar
das wg ziehen oder wie läuft das ab ja
es ist nicht so dass das wir dann auch
immer wieder quasi dabei sein können
gerade jetzt wo
sicherheitsvorkehrungen massiv sind aber
klar wir wissen über den inhalten diese
gespräche weil das erste was ich tue
dann sofort die kollegen den cas anrufen
und sagen er aber sind was wurde
vereinbart also was sollen wir jetzt tun
also was sind die schritte und
normalerweise
hat man dann leider wenig zu berichten
sondern ja wann hat gesprochen aber wir
aber eigentlich nicht nicht viel gutes
dann zu hören und das ist natürlich
enttäuschend